ja in der dritten Woche ging es
ordentlich ab wir haben mit dem
stummgewergchossen orfis Sport gemacht
und uns weiterhin
[Musik]
durchgekämpft ja und dann kam noch was
dazu der
ABC
[Musik]
wir machen jede Woche Kraft und
Ausdauersport und dabei W unsere
Fortschritte
gemessen und ich bin es einfach leiand
dass man merkt dass man sportlicher und
schneller
wird
ich habe echt Respekt gehabt am Anfang
vom schießen war natürlich sehr nervös
aber die Ausbilder war die ganze Zeit
für mich
da es ist definitiv eine neue Erfahrung
für
mich und ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt
was mich in der nächsten Woche
[Musik]
erwartet